at least 44 people have died after a
passenger plane crashed in Nepal a
spokesperson for the airline Yeti has
said there were multiple foreign
Nationals on board including one Irish
National the twin engine ATR 72 was
flying from the capital Kathmandu and
went down in pakora in the west of the
country officials say it was carrying 72
people 68 passengers and four crew
members a warning
this next video shows the moments
leading up to the plane crash and you
may find it very disturbing
foreign
's worst plane disaster since 2018 and
rescue workers have been scouring the
hillside where that plane went down
Nepal's government have set up a panel
to investigate the cause of the crash
let's speak now to bhadra Sharma who's a
journalist in the capital Kathmandu
badra what do we know about exactly what
happened
uh I have spoken with the chief District
officer just few minutes ago he told me
36 people uh were dead means the dead
body of 36 people away taken to the
hospital and the rescules are still
trying to retrieve the dead bodies from
the crash site officials from the Nepal
Army Nepal police and the locals been
there at the grass side and the two
helicopters are being used for the
rescue of prison signed the statistic
administer administrator was telling me
that there is no chance of risking any
passengers alive and Rescuers are
struggling just to drive the body
because that grass side lies in the
George and it's been a bit difficult
there and the government has announced a
holiday for tomorrow to Monday this
tragic incidents and the Prime Minister
home ministers they are all going to the
airport and instructed the authorities
um no strong on turn further rescue
missions in the meantime the relatives
of those disease they have gathered at
the Kathmandu airport they've been
protesting demanding uh that the
condition of their
loved ones should be known right now
and
it's per the details provided by the
officials on the grass side plan has
been grasped into three pieces that's
why they've been saying they're seeing
the people alive from that class side
remains impossible yet
okay padra thank you so much um Badgers
journalist in Kathmandu there thank you